- And Roseburg, which
of course, has seen one
of the very many mass
killings of recent years.
Bobby Kennedy spoke there
ten days before he was shot.
And he was warned by the
Sheriff, "Don't talk gun control.
There's a whole bunch of Lumberjacks here,
they're very gun oriented..."
they're all Second Amendment,
they don't say Second Amendment back then,
they just said, "pro-gun people
and you better not do it."
So he walked out and gave
a pro-gun control speech
right in their face.
Which is very Bobby just
like talking to students
about they shouldn't
have their deferments.
He was very direct with people
and he'd challenge them.
He was not a, he was not
a pander bear at all,
unlike almost every politician today is.
And he said you gotta do guns
and he talked about the
case of mail order rifles.
Like the one that killed his brother.
A mail order rifle.
And he talked about the ridiculous case,
it may have been
apocryphal, it seems crazy.
That somebody on death row ordered a rifle
and they brought it, this
Post Office delivered it.
I have no idea what klutz
in the post office said,
"Oh, it's a rifle, I know it's
a rifle, but he ordered it,
I gotta do it, you know..."
The days of Amazon coming early.
But, you know, he talked
about that and he said,
"People with mental conditions
shouldn't be getting guns.
Kids shouldn't be getting guns."
He gave all the reasons we give today.
For people who have mental handicaps
that are killing people
like this marital dispute
or Mother-In-Law dispute or whatever.
I can't believe it, they're fairly common.
You know, you can't get
rid of Mother-In-Laws,
but how about looking at the guns?
And it was as you say
Sir, he was in Roseburg.
Which later became the
scene of a mass killing,
and he's begging people.
And I put that in a column
to the Times two weeks
ago saying, "They always
say right after the killing
let's not talk politics now."
Because they wait for two weeks
when no one's talking about guns.
And of course you've got to talk politics,
if it's an immigrant who shoots somebody,
immediately, Trump's talking
about immigration law.
So he doesn't have any
problem jumping on the button.
And playing a political card immediately.
You gotta talk gun control
when there's been a killing.
That's when you do focus on things.